次に今朝8月ずっと一緒に暮らしていた弟がこの家を旅立ちました
[音楽]
う
ぽんぽんぽんぽんぷーそんな悲しくないっていうのはそんな彼らしくないけどか寂しい
ですねずっと一人暮らしになっていたかな一人暮らしがすごい好きだったんですけど.
ねふたり生活を1か月ちゃんとやってみてしゃべれる人がいつもいるのってすごいいい
なって思いました
肇社長でちょっと役は悲しい気もする動画トリマーそう結果8月時間があったら
いろんな言えば動画見てたんですけど
ホテルと親分とダンテがか何でもしないように誰かが勝手にその人たちのアプリを作っ
てたんですよ
いいなぁ
いいなぁ張ってにアプリできるってすごいなんかこう
イラッとするよねちょっとうまく言えないんですけどなんかいいよねでもどうなんか
自分の後に作ってありがとう発展に勝手に誰か僕鍋で作ってくれないかなと思ったが
ありました
フォアはず目社長ってことも俺に対するクイズっていうことですよねこれ肇社長に向け
てのアプリなんても僕はやるしかありませんので今日はこのどこがど誰かが知らない
けど勝手に無断で作ったクイズファー肇社長のアプリをやっていこうと思います
ていん
ダイレクトな広告だな youtube 1 youtube に youtube
さん
4567価値とありますこれ順番にやっていけばいいのかね一番和美たちは何年生まれ
もうこれはネームも多分皆さん知っていると思いますよ90あ違う1993寝ると
あんちょっとずつ次いきますがこれなんでそれに簡単だよ誕生日は僕はですねあの
バレンタインで言うまでです皆さん覚えておいて下さいね2月14
アンチョビそれぞれ血液型やっぱ天才っぽいんで ab型なんすよね
それか自分のことだから全部わかって当然なんですよね高生のころは生徒会て服買い
そうになるなどしグループ内の端っこにいるタイプだったと言う
そうなんですよ中だったら取り複製とか時間がねぇよって気がないなぁ強く男の副生徒
会長だったんですけどなんかこうねグループの中でも目立たないポジションにずっとい
たタイプで動画を撮るのは中学
時代から好きだったやぐら中学時代携帯持ってないかところ違います
友達と遊び感覚でズボン穿いた桃パンツを脱ぐ動画などを撮影したやってましたね
そうそうバスケットボール部で打ち込んでいたため大学受験期まで成績良くなかったが
当時付き合っていた彼女は聖戦に行けで遠方維新が空気見たため1日10時間ほどの
受験勉強はずメモ術コーナー1を出すまでになった
詳しいななってるんですよそうなんですよが良くなかったです
決して上のほうじゃなかったんですけど止めてからもうこれですよ s ランカーこれ
はもう本人だから当然だよ
2番やってみよセンター試験本番がも知る100点低いてすとなり高校の教員から進め
て第一志望ではなかったし空てくれ進学した学校名を掛けレザーコーヒー
はは
静岡大学ですはい運営
そっか150体下がったんだった詳しいななんでこんな黒水の2011年2月大学の
同級生の動画チームはじめ看板に組
俺待って行っちゃった2011年
多分あってるうん
あ
2010年代初めて投稿した動画の再生回数は3回だったいやいや俺覚えてますよ
これは12回でした
姉さんかいたっけ自分で終わら仲介再生したから確か12回ですこれ間違ってますよ
イタリアに行った時いくら部分撮られた
にゃんなことを思い出させないで甘い4000円ですよおいら自分だからわかるけどさ
ハンドクリーム
ハッチしづらい質問だな駄目だよこんな顔をレゴがないは待ってすごい
止めでわざとぶり返さないでどんなけぶり返すの投入しません
[音楽]
幸せ書く内容だったね肇社長は2015年7月にまたもに引っ越しを公表する
した気がするで女の覚えてないよ
あったねっあっ何か着てる
loop
30分叩き続けてはないんですよ叩き続けてはなかったんですけど30分が家の前で
待ってたんで叩き続けたのねやっただけ続けてないよ納得しちゃったよちょい
なんか待つよ歪んだようなはじめ本名出るはいその通りでございます
では漢字で書くと本名は一致では違うよ
元気の源元気にてほしいから現在なしですで弟は健なんですけどたければ健康どけって
書いて
件と犬みたいの玄間だけど名前を変えて始めたきれません
結構マメ知識だねうん所属日は覚えてますが4月1日ですエイプでフールで嘘をついて
世間を騒がせた覚えがある
なんか軽い僕の自己紹介動画みたいになってしまいました
が良く出来ている本当に誰か作った人中で果てに作ってるか
ショットされる
ブームに怒られるかもしれませんか僕は知らないですよ興味ある方は行ってみたらいい
と思います
俺を進めればいいので怒られても知らないかじゃあ
[音楽]
4日
ani
car
[音楽]